das wort führung schießen im rahmen der
gegenseite gemeinsamen gefechts und
schießausbildung der theresianischen
militärakademie
ich bin in der ggs eingeteilt bei der
schieß organisation und habe mir damit
die planungsaufgaben für das
kampfgruppen schießen und der nächsten
buch gewonnen
am spannendsten
bei dieser übung der gsa 2015 fand ich
das zusammenwirken der gesamten teile
des steirers der flieger der
infanteriekompanie sowie der schweren
mächte
darum gegangen den jahrgängen
vorzuführen wieder verkrampfter
verbundenen waffen aussieht und
besonders gut gefallen hat mir dabei die
koordinierung über den funk auf mit zu
hören und die wirkungen ziel zu sehen
jährige lernte wovon dass es reibungslos
funktionieren kann das wirklich gut
koordiniert und vor allem eigentlich das
bundes an facetten sehr große
möglichkeiten kapitels und darstellt und
wurde ich sehr eng zusammen greifen
zurück
die nah gesehen der store gewaltiger
planungsaufwand dahintersteckt und man
kann sehr gut ahnen was dann im realen
gefecht für die kommandanten für
aufgaben bevor stehen und wie schwierig
das dann im einsatz wie es das ganze zu
patentieren